welcome everybody I'm John Rogers I
teach in the English department and I'm
here to welcome you to the first lecture
in a series of lectures on utopia but
before I introduce our distinguished
guests I want to thank the Whitney
Humanities Center and especially I want
to thank Richard and Barbara Frankie for
their generous sponsorship of this
lecture series and also the the
undergraduate seminar to which the
lecture series is a is attached it's a
seminar called utopia I have the
privilege of teaching it it's both in
the humanities major and the English
major and in it these wonderful students
all of whom are here thank you for that
are we're doing a whirlwind
cross-section of the of the utopian
tradition we started with Plato's
Republic and mores utopia moved on to
the 17th century with bacon Margaret
Cavendish and Gerrard Winstanley 18th
century Jonathan Swift's corrosives
send-up of the utopian tradition and in
Gulliver's Travels and Russo's political
philosophy today Marx's Communist
Manifesto and we'll spend another couple
of weeks in the 19th century with
Bellamy Morris and Gillman until we get
to the world of science fiction in the
20th and 21st century the final work
that we'll be looking at will be the
really beautiful 2014 novel by Chang
Railly called on such a full sea if you
haven't if you haven't read it you you
really should let me explain to you or
just announced you the the two other
lectures that will be part of this
series and I want to make sure you mark
your calendars we will have so young
Chui from Queens College you'll be
speaking in this room also at 5:00 p.m.
on a Thursday but on November 20th and
so young we'll be talking about
dystopian poetics and the imagination of
North Korea and she'll be assisting the
seminar when we look at the science the
early science fiction novel by
sahteen called we and the final event of
the series will be the presence of Chang
the great Chang Railly himself who will
be here on Thursday December 4th at 5
p.m.
actually he'll be downstairs in the
auditorium and he'll be giving us a
reading from from bonamo on such a full
sea it occurs to me only now and I I'm
pretty sure this is a coincidence and
that I hadn't
I hadn't even figured this out earlier
that all three speakers have a Yale
connection today's speaker received his
PhD in English at Yale so young Chui
will be coming next and Chang Rayleigh
were both English majors at Yale College
but now it's time to introduce the Yale
PhD Christopher Kendrick is a professor
of English at Loyola University Chicago
I think by all accounts he's the
preeminent Marxist critic of Renaissance
and early modern English literature
so far he's the author of two too
important books Milton a study and
ideology and form that was the
dissertation I'm assuming and the 2004
utopia carnival and Commonwealth in
Renaissance England
Kendricks identity is a Milton astiz is
a profound one many of his analyses of
particular readings of Milton are I
think they've established themselves as
class classics the reading of
Areopagitica for example which I think
came from the dissertation has really
achieved the status of Orthodoxy and
it's a bold
it's a bold reading and it's really now
passes for truth about what we know of
the inner complicated workings of
Milton's treatise utopia Carnival and
Commonwealth is a mammoth work of
literary criticism it's nimble and
sophisticated in its theoretical
bearings
and it's unspeakably ambitious in its in
its scope Chris gives us readings of
extensive readings of more robble a
Marlow Shakespeare Thomas nashe and
Francis Bacon and he inter lodged the
whole thing with innumerable figures and
texts that you didn't know existed
and that you're grateful to have been
introduced to by professor Kendrick
Chris Kendrick I think is really a rare
animal in in the Academy he's he's a
brilliant close reader and he has a
really powerful command of a whole range
of theoretical theoretical discourses or
languages and and with these two
strengths it seems to me he is a master
at the discovery of and the analysis of
of contradiction of literary cultural
social contradiction he can identify a
contradiction and articulate it
beautifully and explain to you why it's
so central and important in a way that
nobody else can and I don't know I kind
of like to think that contradiction is a
is a fact and a mode that Chris Kendrick
has always embraced as a graduate
student at Yale he worked with one of
the members of our audience here I'm
Lesley Richmond my colleague in the
English department and he also worked
with another adviser Fredric Jameson who
was then a professor in the French
department at Yale
maybe it's tempting to see maybe it's
tempting to see that Chris Kendrick
splendid gifts as a critic or in some
way symptomatic of the contradictory
formation that one might think his
dissertation committee was but I think
that would be I think that would be a
mistake surely he's selected knowingly
selected two advisers understanding that
they're conflicted or maybe only
seemingly
conflicted perspectives we're exactly
what he wanted from them I prefer to
think of it in that in that light in any
case let's welcome Chris Kendrick we'll
be talking today about marks Winstanley
and Morris utopian thinking and practice
in the Communist Manifesto the law of
freedom and news from nowhere
thank you John for that incredibly
generous introduction and thank you for
inviting me here it's great to be back
at Yale
I haven't had been here for a long time
and it brings back fond memories of what
it was like to have hair for example and
what I would like to have ideas I can't
remember a time when I had so many ideas
or felt like I did because what happened
was when I left I realized that many of
them I just been picking up from people
in my environment from students graduate
students and undergraduates as well as
from the teachers here so this is a talk
that's going to come in three parts and
mostly I'll be talking about when
Stanley's law of freedom and a platform
and Marx's marx and engels the Communist
Manifesto and William Morris is news
from Norman nowhere at times I try to
give descriptions that'll help people
who haven't read these text or read them
recently
at other times I'm hoping that people
will ask me to fill them in after the
talk I hope it's clear all the way
through so to begin with a bit about the
manifesto it's it's not a utopian text
actually in some ways militantly not as
its characterization of utopian
socialism as a now obsolete phase on the
road to communism goes to show yet it
encourages we're
election on the relationship between
communism as the principles of a new
political party and utopianism as the
function of envisioning good or better
societies I'll be suggesting that the
manifesto implicitly advocates a
readjustment in the relation between
political practice and social vision and
projects achieve communism at the time
of the freeing of utopian vision the
tract also encourages reflection on the
historical relation between the
manifesto as a genre and the utopia
which proves to be a closer and more
vexed relation than one might think
but I wanted to begin by remembering
that
niccolò machiavelli composed the prints
three or four years before Thomas More
wrote utopia many critics have observed
that these texts respond to aspects of
the same European situation
more specifically utopia is seen as a
reaction against the kind of politics
Machiavelli advocates in the prince
something close to which is sketched by
his low dais in his imaginary
description of a counseling session at
the French Court this would make it
according to Antonio Gramsci is reading
of Machiavelli and in his the modern
Prince a reaction against a manifesto
the Prince Graham she argued was trained
closely on the problem of how to achieve
Italian national unity in a political
situation defined by feuding city-states
and an opportunistic papacy and over
determined by the predatory new
absolutist monarchies of Spain and
France Louis al qussair elaborating this
reason reading adds that the prince
virtually invents the fundamental
political idea of the conjuncture and
that the social laws Machiavelli refers
to are important only insofar as they
contribute to the arrangement of social
and political forces into which the
practice of the desired political agency
must intervene if a nation-state is to
be formed if Italy is to be formed as a
cont
that agency and Machiavelli's day in
situation could only take the form of
prints
it couldn't be a party grant she argued
memorably that Machiavelli's concluding
panegyric to lorenzo de'medici or to the
possible prince disease caste which is
probably the least interesting aspect of
the text to most modern readers both
rallies the constituency of the new
prince the forward-thinking middle class
into effective being thus clarifying who
the agency and book are really for and
also for grounds it's sheerly willful
character on the willful character of
this politics Machiavelli famously
claimed that Cesare Borgia would have
succeeded in welding the nation together
if he hadn't fallen deathly ill for just
the wrong two months he wrote in hope of
a second luckier Caesar but gram she
judges such a repetition all but
impossible and caused the prince
a utopian political manifesto bringing
the idea of a unifying politics into
existence rather than the thing now more
you Tokyo might well be seen as the
invention of the manifestos generic
opposite number most of its pages
assemble a new kind of national unity
from what's emerging in the absolute
monarchies and focus on the state itself
the new imaginary socio-political entity
rather than the way to get there yet in
the move through this straightforward
satire of book 1 to the bottomless
satire of book 2 elements of what could
be a manifesto elements that could be
framed as conjuncture or some part of it
are encountered I'm referring to the two
main episodes in the dialogue of council
in book 1 the hypothetical advising
session at the French Court in which the
dynamic of absolutist politics in
warfare is captured and then Hitler
day--is memory of an attempted
intervention at Cardinal Morton's table
in England in which mass and capitalist
downsizing of retinues and on manners
lead to popper is a
and unemployment on an unprecedented
scale this last episode makes for an
English difference and helps hit
Linnaeus locate private property
specifically as the root cause of
European self dispossession it does lens
point to the manifesto that doesn't
actually materialize but what preserves
the sense of a manifesto is the way in
which book one's critique prepares for
utopian communism popper ization and
power seeking are of course the things
to be kept out of utopia what utopian
institutions have been devised to
prevent yet they're also felt as basic
conditions somehow of these institutions
popularization especially as the basis
of equality but power drive as the basis
of utopian flexibility or mobility
they're able to react to things and come
up with social solutions really quickly
the King utopias in Moore's work in a
sense stands for a new political agency
that enacts the manifesto transforms
England or Europe into utopia this
latent relationship contributes
significantly to the uncanny polyvalent
interest of book two of utopia where the
utopia itself is described it's
plausible and the familiarity of most of
its customs and institutions yet
incomprehensible and impossible for its
basic difference hopelessly desirable
yet scary as well I'd suggest that
consequent utopias need to include
incomplete or latent manifestos so now
to win Stanley's law of freedom in a
platform of 1652
which is a key text in utopian tradition
partly because like several utopian
works it's not meant as a utopia
what's it meant as then the simple
answer is that it's a platform like the
title says the outline of a constitution
which is to say the outline of an
outline but the gesture involved in the
offer of the platform to Oliver Cromwell
he dedicates this work to Cromwell and
the world gives it both a manifesto like
and a utopian claim this is a text that
between the two genres for the manifesto
aspect it's important to remember the
digger pamphlets and the political
experiments of which they were apart
when Stanley was the spokesperson for a
movement that he came to we call the
diggers they called themselves the true
Levellers at first a communist agrarian
movement when Stanley hardly mentions
the true leveling time in the law but
everyone must have been aware that when
Stanley's Constitution came out of it
and amounted to the digger Summa part of
the interest of the digger occupation of
common lands was that it was premise on
long-term changes in forms of property
digger ideologies basic ethical
opposition between the spirit of common
preservation and the spirit of self
preservation between the spreading
sharing Jesus embedded in creation and
the enclosing devil of private
appropriation this opposition could be
seen and inscribed in common and private
spaces the no-man's land all over the
kingdom were taking on a more common
character with the ongoing move to
absolute property and became the
collective property of those without
those who'd inherited the spirit of
common preservation especially the
agrarian working-class and unemployed
though when Stanley often disclaimed
designs on private spaces his formula to
the working class was you stick to your
lands and let us keep ours still the
digger agenda was clearly to activate
the division between common and private
tenancy spaces to enliven it with class
struggle no man should work for higher
was a formula they used early on that
was almost as resident in the early
pamphlets as work together he bred
together these are two statements from
on high that when Stanley claimed to
have heard so that was an agrarian
strike at least at the beginning of this
movement in view so when Stanley's
quitting this project this utopian
politics - Oliver Cromwell in the
preface through the law of freedom he
purports to hope that this strong man
can work out the kind of real politic
appropriate to convince the English
ruling class to adopt community of goods
and he helpfully suggest that he might
begin as the diggers did by setting up
the new society on the wastelands it's
certainly worth noting that when Stanley
wrote or revised the law in a period
when the Commonwealth having secured
itself from foreign invasion was proving
to be politically unstable and just
before the rigged election of one of the
most radical Parliament's that England
ever enjoyed this political flux and the
fact that Cromwell was authentically a
man of the Spirit
probably prompted when Stanley to
publish and address Cromwell still he
concludes the pamphlet with a poem
lamenting that he's been given the
knowledge of what could be which cuts
him off from the rest of his race and
leaving the obvious in probability of
Cromwell's conversion to communism aside
he does lay it down as a law in the
platform that no one who has bought or
profited from lands taken over by the
Commonwealth should be allowed allowed
to stand for office in his society which
would rule krumin Cromwell himself and
many of his close supporters right out
as governors unless exceptions were to
be made four founding fathers so the
readers main sense is that when Stanley
seizes the occasion to publish his
thoughts subsequent to the digger
experiment and to work out the social
vision as well as the laws that it
presupposed in effect to publish the
Utopia born from n its a peculiarly
realistic literary literary utopia yet
it may be asked to be used like one
appreciated for its socially uncanny
effect its institutions and total set up
both plausible or close to us yet
impossible or far
when Stanley's elaboration yields a
reasonably definite version of communism
whose strengths and weaknesses as such
stem from its rigor as a solution to the
digger program or the problem it left
behind one might summarize what's
happening in it oversimplifying a lot of
course in terms of the systemic mixture
of Francis Bacon's scientific ideology
into the religion of the spreading
Creator God found in the early pamphlets
the spreading God is replaced by what
might be called the religion of the
earth when Stan Lee's first chapter is
devoted to deriving a politics from the
principle that each person has a right
to the earth and its fruits the society
of self-preservation we understand has
misread the earth which is as communist
in its nature as the air there's nothing
new here
exactly exactly common preservation
sharing is a has was always a basic
digger law but the religion has become
less vitalistic lee pantheistic and more
philosophical part of the reason for
this shift emerges when it transpires
that the right to the Earth's fruits
includes a right to know the earth and
this is new when Stan Lee's free society
requires education for all first into
literacy and languages and then into a
trade or trades conceived in modified
Baconian fashion of involving and
implying arts associated with basic
aspects of the earth in what is an
effect a new vocational division of
knowledge the scientific college of
Bacon's new Atlantis the house of
Solomon has been decanted into the
economy along with the entire
educational system of wind Stanley
of when Stanley's in Utopia if the coat
Baconian science tends to secularize
when Stanley's religion his religion
tends to popularize and universalize
science in turn now on the one hand this
combination helps to explain the most
obvious weakness in when Stanley's setup
in the law of freedom its indifference
to economic matters especially its
treatment of the common store
storehouses
as if stocking them and dispensing from
them will be a simple affair if the
distribution is a matter of core
religious belief subject to expertise
than the assumption that things will
simply come right is not so hard to
understand
indeed we might be prodded to consider
that our own modern understanding of
economy as a fatally complex sphere
tending to dislike this equilibrium in
crisis is relative is ideological on the
other hand in the Baconian religion of
the earth seems to determine the
separation of the family unit and its
associated patriarchal ism as key
features of when stanley's communism it
is a patriarchal utopia one might say
that that they are estranged and being
taken for granted yet it's important to
note that it's an astonishingly benign
the form of patriarchy that the religion
of the earth assumes a patriarchy in
which the origin of government is
located not in the father's authority
but in his sympathetic response to an
obligation in the face of his children's
cry of necessity in what amounts then to
a recognition of human prematurity as
the animating principle of the whole
collective it's a patriarchy that leads
to the legal definition of rape as a
capital crime in that it deprives the
victim of her bodily freedom it's
assumed that it will be a heterosexual
rates meanwhile in the combination of
science and religion yields at least one
high utopian moment in which the reader
for utopia is rewarded with a relatively
full sense of the quality of the culture
and daily life aimed at in this act of
constitutional imagining and with it a
recognition of utopian consequence when
Stanley would have the Sabbath preserved
as a day of rest and of communal coming
together the ritual if that's the right
word is telling there'll be no
conventional preaching of Scripture of
course
since there's no Christian clergy rather
he that is chosen Minister for that year
in the parish will first provide news
from the rest of the nation to do
especially with
health outbreaks of disease and food
shortages and so on then some part of
the country's laws will be read from
though not discoursed upon or preached
so that the simple letter can be
absorbed by the people and then third
and this I'm gonna be reading from the
first quotation on the handout now
because the minds of people generally
love discourses the Minister may make
speeches of three sorts first to declare
the acts and passages of former ages and
governments setting forth the benefit of
freedom by well-ordered governments as
in Israel's Commonwealth secondly
speeches may be made of all Arts and
Sciences some one day some another as in
physics chair jure astrology and and so
on several other Sciences thirdly
speeches may be made sometimes of the
nature of mankind of his darkness and
his light his weakness at of his
strength of his love and his envy and
this is that which the Ministry of
churches generally aim but only that
they confound their knowledge by
imaginary study bacon who always
preached the compatibility of
Christianity and science the harmonious
separation of the books of knowledge in
the Bible would have recoiled from this
Sunday school yet
when Stanley the displacement of the
separation his running of science and
religion together
it surely is strong miss reading
capturing and putting to use something
essential about bacon scientific
enthusiasm on riddling the secrecy that
haunts Solomon's house in the New
Atlantis at the same time when Stanley's
Sunday ritual calls up what I've called
the ground religion of mores utopia
which Institute's a parallel between
religious belief and economy between the
One God and the many on the one hand and
agriculture and the crafts on the other
or one could see when Stanley as
inflecting Blake Bacon's religion back
in the direction of Moore's utopian
religion with a secular difference the
presence of the preceding utopia's seems
remarkably organic in this offshoot of
the Revolution and is the more haunting
on account of the text oscillation
between manifest
so and utopia hmm so the first page of
the Communist Manifesto proper defines
its purpose in a two-fold way on the one
hand marx and engels will explain why
the spectre of communism has been
haunting Europe why so many false
charges of communism have been hurled
back and forth between parties and power
and the various opposition's why it's
the scare tactic of the day on the other
hand the manifesto will make manifest to
the world the real communism the
political party that is or intends to
embody the specter it is high time the
communists should openly in the face of
the whole world publish their views
their aims their tendencies and meet
this nursery tale of the specter of
communism with a manifesto of the party
itself so the Communist League is no
conspiracy or a secret society it's in
its nature as a new political agency to
announce its means and ends to go public
and indeed internationally public this
is a text written to be translated so
you don't need to feel guilty about it
if you read it can only read it in
English why has it become the time to
announce communism the currency of the
specter is cast as an indication of the
new conjuncture that demands
manifestation now evidently it was the
political crises on the continent in
1848 especially in France and Germany
that provoked the composition of the
manifesto in early 1848 and not for
example in 1847 when everything that
goes into it was in place already or in
1850 but if these form part of the
actual conjuncture to which it responds
they're not specified as such they're
simply understood what's rather provided
as conjuncture
is a vision of world history a big story
a macro historical narrative this
features the ongoing arrival of the
bourgeoisie with its destruction of the
old societies of rank and traditional
privilege and its unleashing of
prodigious wealth
human productive power yet it also
involves the culmination of capitalism
its arrival at its own limits with the
transparent polarization of society into
two camps and the outpacing of relations
by forces of production in the part of
the manifesto everyone agrees is the
most impressive and memorable bourgeois
and proletarians Marx and Engels paint a
tremendously energetic picture prospect
of world history understood as class
struggle breaking through into the
present and the local clarifying the
human and the social in doing so that's
canvas a few moments of this
clarification mmm they'll be for Marx
and Engels focused on the creative
destruction both historically and
intrinsically characteristic of
capitalist economies and this quote I
think is on your handout constant
revolutionising of production
uninterrupted disturbance of all social
conditions everlasting uncertainty and
agitation distinguished the bourgeois
epoch from all earlier ones all fixed
fast frozen relations with their train
of ancient and venerable prejudices and
opinions are swept away all new-formed
ones become antiquated before they can
ossify all that is solid melts into air
all that is holy is profaned and man is
at last compelled to face with sober
senses his real conditions of life and
his relations with his kind this is an
arresting passage and it's so often
quoted perhaps because it winds up
suggesting that capitalism simply
unveils or exposes the truths of the
human in itself it's an important moment
in the tract but more often capitalist
dynamism and unveiling is cast as
unveiling the truth of class domination
the second quotation it's resolved the
bourgeoisie has resolved personal worth
into exchange value and in place of the
numberless indefeasible chartered
freedoms I set up that single
unconscionable freedom free trade in one
word for exploitation veiled by
religious and political
illusions it has substituted naked
shameless direct brutal exploitation so
these two moments depict capitalism as
installed and as the end of traditional
societies of rank and religion privilege
and illusion but the bourgeoisie is not
and cannot be simply the end the last
class the system outpaces itself another
quotation third moment the productive
forces at the disposal of society no
longer tend to further the development
of the conditions of bourgeois property
on the contrary
they've become too powerful for these
conditions by which they are fettered
and so soon as they overcome these
fetters they bring disorder into the
whole of bourgeois society endanger the
existence of bourgeois property the
conditions of bourgeois society are too
narrow to comprise the wealth created by
them and then in a fourth moment or
aspect to win its way to catch up with
itself the bourgeoisie must promote the
proletariat both by expanding and
increasing its numbers and by enlisting
its political services in its fight
against other classes the revolutionary
temporality associated with the
bourgeois class this culmination that
constantly outpaces itself defines the
conjuncture according to the manifesto
as is often been remarked the manifesto
seems less a text about what is to be
done then about world history this is so
because the main aim of the Communist
Party in this text is to create and
maintain working-class consciousness
which is to say solidarity across the
ranks of the class in light of a vision
of the whole classes key role in social
production and struggle and world
history is cast in the manifesto as
enabling class consciousness though the
second section called proletarians and
communists is not as exciting as section
1 the question and answer session to
which it's mostly given over amounts to
an effective demonstration of the value
of class consciousness the we of the
dialogue is the party speaking
articulating the thought of the class
and has it x a spectral quality for this
the back and forth can be understood as
a dialogue at the end of time or time as
we know it anyway since the questions
and objections that the bourgeoisie
poses are immemorial ways of defending
class hierarchy ancient proper tarry and
common sense what will become of women
in the family if all is made common why
would people work if they can't own
anything what would happen to
individuality and freedom the final
answer to this last is particularly
effective I think it's a quote ok you
were approached us with intending to do
away with a form of property the
necessary condition for whose existence
is the non-existence of any property for
the immense majority of the society you
were approached us with intending to do
away with your property precisely so
that is just what we intend it's a
Marxist axiom that revolutions will
involve violence because ruling classes
can't be persuaded to give up their
possessions and power still ideological
struggle is primary if the Communists
view of capitalist property is class
oppression masking as individual right
and freedom should become widespread or
in other words if working class
consciousness is achieved the likelihood
grows so goes the reasoning of mass
bourgeois defection Gareth Stedman Jones
argument in the penguin it's a very long
introduction very good introduction to
the penguin penguin edition of the
communist manifesto his argument as to
the route by which marx and engels come
to their vision of class struggle seems
right it results from the combination of
a German dialectic with Scottish or
political economic modes of distribution
yet Stedman Jones appears to
underestimate the novelty and
distinctiveness of the manifest manifest
those vision its focalization of class
struggle through capitalism's final
contradictory dynamic which remained a
defining moment in what was to become
Marxism or prasat perhaps I should say
most Marxism
and which was modified rather than
cancelled by the later marks of capital
especially one could put the chief
qualification made by Marx's study of
the workings of the capitalist economy
which took up the rest of his life
pretty much after the manifesto in terms
of capitalism social transparency the
later Marx famously allowed that his key
innovation was not the idea that class
struggle motored history the better
political economists for example were in
possession of this idea rather it lay in
the idea of surplus value and ideas
around it this complex of ideas
explained the secret of the so called
fetishism of commodities in other words
how the play of prices on the capitalist
market the dick type dictates the
distribution of resources and seems to
create profit disguises the exploitation
of the working class be lying its
structural centrality to the system the
fetishism of commodities comes to be the
fundamental illusion of capitalism in
its everyday life according to Marx and
far from replacing the privileges and
illusions of traditional societies it
allows them to be remote evaded used to
divide and rule this doesn't mean that
the vision of the manifesto is ruled out
it becomes more crucial in ways but it
comes to be understood as a rare moment
less than an evident ability and this
tends to restore utopianism to a
structural political function we can see
how this is if we turn to the third
section of the manifesto which canvasses
the specters not of communism but of
socialism with which communism has come
to compete it's interesting and
symptomatic of his under appreciation of
Marx's distinctiveness that fed when
Jones castigates this part as Marx's
invention having no relation to the
living political languages he borrowed
from and allotting ideas no agency a
claim that's obviously wrong
since Marx is promoting communist
socialism and what's a battle over
socialism's in this whole section
marx is simply putting to work the kind
of questions concerning class
representation and interest that emerge
once history is understood as class
struggle it's basic Marxist ideological
analysis the distinction that's relevant
to us here is that between utopian
socialism and communist socialism other
classes represent their own interests by
using socialist ideas associated with
and intending to attract the support of
the working-class utopian and communist
socialism are alike in representing the
working class but they represented in
different phases utopian socialism
emerges and continues to think on the
terrain of the proletariat at an early
stage of development the communists of
the night of the 1840s represent the
proletariat of a later more developed
phase having profited from growth in
numbers and the bourgeoisie political
education the utopian socialists caste
the working class always in so insofar
as it's a passive suffering class and
their proposals to redress the suffering
feature the more or less wild ideas of
an individual the Communists based their
plans on both the suffering and the
emerging social and political power of
the working class and make their main
aim to reduce capitalist property whose
abolition will mean the cancel of the
cancellation of classes such this period
of the expropriation of capital is
implicitly but clearly defined as
socialism utopian planning the
discussion and decisions as to the good
or better society will come after and
will be conducted so it's implied by
what will now be the people not
projected by individuals the Marx and
Engels greatly admired Robert Owen and
Charles Freire the great utopians that
came before him so the manifestos
harshness toward utopia is presumably
owing to the contemporary strength of
utopian socialism on the radical left
still one understands the logic of what
sometimes called the Marxist ban on
utopia the first task for projected by
the conjuncture
to help the people free themselves after
which they can be expected to learn to
dream on their own yet if the ban is
taken literally it's clearly an
undirected separation of the negative
from the positive one notes that some of
the measures to be commonly adopted in
the attack on property are positive and
have a utopian ring the vocational
ization of education for example which
they do propose but better this is a
good place to remember the later Marx
and Engels response to the activities
and measures of the Paris Commune in
1871 when it went about setting up a
citizen's government during its 72 days
of freedom in the spring of that year
with the powers of Europe counting the
hours outside the gates the communes
mixture of direct and representative
democracy it's swapping of political
roles
it's impromptu rituals all this was for
marx and engels the people showing the
way in effect remaking the socialist
phase and what was a utopian political
experiment their reaction marx and
engels reaction indicates that the
manifestos ban on utopia ought to be
understood as a change in the status of
utopian practice and thinking its
integration in the communist political
practice for them okay this in turn
suggests that the debates within the
utopian tradition as a whole utopias of
industry versus utopias of industry of
leisure the City versus the country
small-scale production versus
large-scale production all this would
become the raw material of a post
communist utopianism so many problems to
be solved and from which to choose
and now to news from nowhere
Morris is utopian romance divides into
three main parts after an argument at a
meeting of the league about what
socialism will look like Morris wakes up
in the year 2100 - in his home in
Hammersmith now no longer his home he
slowly realizes but a communal
guesthouse in a communal society after
his initial friends realized that he
needs orientation he's taken by dick a
boatman who serves as his escort
throughout his stay in the future
through what had been London to Dix old
kinsman hansman Hammond an amateur
historian the trip shows London to be
much d congested and contra fide but
still something of a population hub this
the first part is the most conventional
part of the utopia the middle part of
the book is occupied with a
question-and-answer session between
Hammond and Morris or William guest as
he's called in the book who's whose
focus is on how the change came how
England moved from commercialism to
communism in the first half of the 20th
century in the third part guest is
escorted by Dickon his love Clare up up
the Thames to Morris's Country Estate
where dick has promised friends to take
part in the harvesting of hay and what
will be a very very much a working
festival a Maine beautiful paradox of
the first and third parts is that guest
finds the dream harder to bear as the
contrast between past and present or his
his present and their future diminishes
and as he comes to know people to form
friendships as the party moves upstream
to Kelmscott the landscape grows less
foreign the country's been less the
spoiled by commercialism and Morris is
coming home but the people becoming more
familiar in their difference recede and
Morris wakes up back in the 19th century
haunted by a dream of communism that he
hopes to make a vision I'm gonna discuss
the second and third episodes here but
first I want to say a few things about
Morris profile as a socialist he did
read Marx's capital volume 1 and
French in 1883 finding it rough going
about convincing and certainly after
that he can be called a Marxist he
called himself a Marxist but he come to
socialism before that on the basis of
Romanticism and a transformative
encounter with John Ruskin especially
his theory of Gothic art for Ruskin
Gothic architecture and medieval
handicrafts in general spoke of a time
when people could work freely together
and take pleasure in their work
the medieval guilds established the
conditions in which labor and art were
not defined against one another and in
which the relation between whole and
part reflected the freedom of the
individual craftsmen within the guild
the larger group
such are disappeared with the breakup of
the guilds which for Morris came
especially with the period of
manufacturer the eighteenth century it's
not too much to say that Morris rebuilt
his life on the basis of Ruskin's theory
of medieval art and it thoroughly
informs his late essays and speeches for
the socialist League which is the best
socialist propaganda that I've read
Morris tenets that in communism work
must become art must involve pleasure in
form and his thesis that in modern
conditions work as art is premised on
rough social equality makes this Marxism
distinctive distinctive but not
idiosyncratic it's tempting to say that
Marx
and Morris disagreed utterly in their
evaluation of the Industrial Revolution
and modern industry for Marx the
Industrial Revolution created the
technology and put in place the social
conditions that make socialism possible
for Morris the Industrial Revolution and
finishing off handicrafts killed workers
pleasure and so was an obstacle to
revolution merely socialism had to go
back behind the industrialism to find
its conditions there is something to
this opposition quite a lot actually but
it's exaggerated the manifesto and other
writings by Marx can leave you with the
feeling that Marx wanted the world to be
a big Factory as the Anoat Theodor
Adorno says somewhere
that was the problem with marks
according to him but I can't read all
the passages threaded through Marx's
work early and late on capitals beasts
killing or dehumanization of labor
without feeling that coming up with the
socialized labor process both gratifying
and meaningful was it taken for granted
part of the communist project for him he
does say as much in a few passages of
Volume three of capital Morris on the
other hand followed Marx in believing
that commercial society produced its
gravediggers and bringing workers
together as a class and he allowed that
the nineteenth century had been
especially remarkable for one thing
making machines to make other machines
he could this gets into news from
nowhere this amounts to a backhanded
recognition of the jump in productivity
capitalism made for and though it's a
tender point with him
Morris must recognize that it's this
increase in the basic productivity of
social labor that makes it possible for
him to conceive of a return to
handicrafts without the guild form in
modern conditions of individualist
equality the core difference between
Marx and Morris would seem to be on the
question of whether factory labor or
what might be called highly socially
analyzed labor can be meaningful and
pleasurable a difference that could only
be resolved through social experiment
and experience if at all I've gone into
this relation between Marx and Morris
because it's significant in the chapters
on how the change came Perry Andersen
held some time ago that the narrative of
revolution in news from nowhere is the
most gripping an impressive episode and
that these pages put on display Morris
remarkable capacity as a political
strategist I agree and would add that
though the revolution episode stands out
from the utopian segments for its
realism it's every bit as personal as
these since Hammond is presented as
Morris alter-ego in the future it's as
if Morris realizing he wouldn't live to
see and tell of the revolution indulges
his strategic skill in effect of history
in making this narrative of the rub
lucien as a contingent necessity a part
of his utopia he's addressing a
traditional complaint about the genre
that it gives you results without the
means to achieve them a complaint that
misses the whole point of utopia is one
would think except that as I'm arguing
consequent utopia is at least in the
quick indicate the way in Morris we have
an actual revolution rather than an
indicated manifesto I do what is
implying that it can work as a manifest
or be translated into one it's bracing I
think by the way to read a fictional
revolution today there are other good
science-fiction ones Kim Stanley
Robinson's one in the Mars trilogy comes
to mind but most novels of the future
today tend to imagine it in terms of
continual capitalist dissolution with
pockets of relative affluence hunkering
down behind walls against a lump and
wilderness of some sort so to describe
to break the story of a revolution and
news from nowhere in two episodes
there's gonna be brutally reductive
because it's pretty complicated but
first of all aggressive unionists or
social democratic politics what Morris
calls state socialism leads to economic
crisis and capitalist reaction then
popular demonstrations bring on
capitalist violence and then vacillation
and in the dearth of food workers take
over shops to feed the people the
state's reaction against this
self-organization prompts a general
strike which soon wins a separate
Council for the workers and then dual
power slides into civil war which is won
by the workers in two years of fighting
okay all through this all through this
there's this a remarkable sense that it
could have happened otherwise I mean the
slipperiness of history is really
stressed it's notable in this outline
that a communist party doesn't play a
leading role in Morris's revolution it's
state socialism or social democracy
rather that winds up forcing a crisis
and one might perhaps see this as do
the manifestos implicit model of
revolution but not really or not at
first the success is the effect of
Morris's realization that social
democracy or unionism was winning out in
the late 1880s over the people who
recognized the necessity of revolution
he has the party emerged from the ranks
of the revolution in process as a result
of perceived necessity without ever
needing to call itself a party the
leading element comes from some old
socialists and revolutionaries and then
from people coming up from the unions
who to meet the occasion one could see
Morris's scenario as confirming Marx and
Engels argument for a party without
ratifying the thing itself and so
without bringing up the Associated
problems to do with a party on the other
hand though the leading members are
essential to the later stages of the
revolution and the war they aren't cast
I think as a structural thing quinone of
revolutionary success the basic causes
of that success are two closely related
popular feelings Unleashed in the
revolution which are described by
Hammond in the pauses of the narrative
the generalizing reflections it
sometimes frustrate guests they are
first are longing for equality and
freedom set in place I think it's
understood by the capitalist stripping
of rank and privilege and accentuated by
the clarification and desperation of the
revolutionary situation this general
feeling it was Hammond surmises that
pushes the workers through but the
longing for equality and freedom turn
out to be closely allied with the second
feeling which kicks in in the
traumatized love after victory
traumatized because of all the
destruction has taken place this is the
need or desire for Kraftwerk and this is
a from a quotation on the sheet at last
and by slow degrees says Hammond
we got pleasure into our work then we
became conscious of that pleasure and
cultivated it and then always gained and
we were happy these deep set attitudes
our instincts our caste is the final
cause of the revolution success if one
to be assigned a medieval unconscious
one might say preserving the knowledge
of and desire for workers form channeled
and activated by proletarian equality
assumes the role of the party in holding
the working class together or since this
unconscious is in fact predicated on the
survival however marginal of handicrafts
is a moment of the social structure it
might be cast as the key uneven
development of the revolutionary
conjuncture in news from nowhere and one
might see this aspect as a positive
criticism of and contribution to the
Communist Manifesto
in fact it seems more realistic to me
than what you've got in the manifesto
more complicated - I'll turn now to the
last episode the trip up the Thames here
we see some of the principles that
Hammond has expositor in the chapters
before and after the war on the
revolution fleshed in narrative Lee
their way of managing love relationships
for example and crime or the way they
make decisions about how way to build
things and things like that we're also
learning new things with each episode
that there's a minor problem of Grubb
grumbling for example and many people
like to live in tents that people whose
main vocation is non-manual
there are such come to group harvests
work and are given easier jobs by the
more expert and so on we might call this
a road utopia I think it's a fairly
common utopian form a main point about
which is that the map of utopia it
offers is almost by definition fairly
incomplete it's a strategy for dealing
with the problem of totality in Utopia
the root principles of the utopia and
Morris those of work pleasure natural
beauty rest equality are effectively
repeated with each stroke of the oars
and new encounter while the basic
outlines they provide are filled in and
over determined with new material more
or less interestingly the rule seems to
be that better utopias and offering a
partial picture will both produce an
effective totality of society as an
overdetermined with coherent whole so
you say this
seem to hang together while also
managing to indicate the interesting
blind spots the unsolved contradictions
in the utopian scene I'd suggest that
the quality of the relation between the
root themes and the complications on the
trip up steam upstream is anticipated
and the process of fleshing in and
unfinish your unveiling problems is
perhaps set in motion by Hammonds
description of the tenor of nowheres
particular communism in the chapter
entitled the beginning of the new life
and this is this would be the last
petition on the sheet he says there and
this is probably the most quoted passage
from news from nowhere
the spirit of the new days of our days
was to be delight in the life of the
world
intense an overweening love of the very
skin and surface of the earth on which
man dwells such as the lover has in the
fair flesh of the woman he loves this I
say was to be the new spirit of the time
all other moods say this had been
exhausted he goes on to contrast this
love of the surface of the earth with
the curiosity of the ancient Greeks to
whom these things were not so much a
means as an end and observes that such
curiosity had already been drained from
the world by the 19th century the
passage is hauntingly beautiful and yet
nagging ly inadequate if it's taken to
refer to the art of work pleasure
similarly the implied association
between sex and handicraft is arresting
but simplifying one the tension or
inadequacy here seems to have to do with
the difference between surface and depth
or form and practice or nature and
culture at any rate some such tension
ripples through the thematic repetitions
and over determinations all the way
upstream insofar as the tension changes
shape it contributes to an effect of
richness of various totality I could
only affirm here that read closely the
episodes are rich in social suggestion
in what d'arco souvent of estrangement
but insofar as the tension is felt as
the same thing as recurrence it seems to
suggest
prediction or a problem or a set of them
our conclude by discussing two of these
one has to do with the idea of nowhere
as an epoch of rest it's in the subtitle
and with the associated ideas of peace
and simplicity
there's no denying the enormous appeal
of these themes as rendered in virtually
every episode of the journey still
Morris's utopians as is often pointed
out are worried by their own happiness
and simplicity they've brought into
being a country that's about is a garden
but they can't write novels but whose
mentioned they began defending their
superficiality
this might be appreciated as just a
witty way of making his people
complicated and so of deflecting
criticism if the simplicity weren't also
made out to be a problem insofar as it
means a lack of interest in history the
idea that nowhere is history lessness
leaves it vulnerable to a fatal choice
down the line a fall back into class
assumes major importance in guests
budding relationship with the kind of a
fairy woman or witch named Ellen who
claims she wants to learn about class
society from him so that she can protect
her children from the old mistakes she's
really a human woman but but she's kind
of cast as a fairy so nowhere it turns
out needs news itself from somewhere
this is formally neat and the theme of
the interdependence of present and
future has point but the trouble is that
the people we've been introduced to as
noted don't seem in need of news they're
much better informed about the past and
the costs of class than the average
nineteenth-century novelistic character
one realizes that part of the problem
here is that rest has meaning only in
relation to unrest anxiety struggle war
and that no where's peace is in fact
always implicitly defined not in itself
but in comparison to the epoch of
capital and this realization tends to
make nowhere seem merely a thematic
effect the badness of the episode with
Ellen not that it's all bad it results
largely from a formal or literary
problem but one suspects that this
problem distracts
something else what no one in nowhere
seems much interested in is it's non
handicraft heavy industry its existence
is no secret true hamon tells guests
matter-of-factly that the utopians use
an improved industrial technology to
produce those necessary goods that can't
be made by handicraft and on the river
guests at one point sees what dick calls
a forced barge plying its way upstream
speedy way upstream performing some
unattractive function evidently it's
interesting to note that this uncurious
people seem to have come up with an
improved form of power cleaner than
steam at least guests asked no questions
about it lest he give his true identity
away now one can imagine an episode in
which guest meets a non manual worker
who organizes factory production or a
manual worker who puts in time in a
force factory in such an episode we
might learn that the modern component of
the economy has shrunk drastically for
example or is gradually being made more
pleasurable we might see its effects on
characters and learn to read it into the
social and natural landscapes logic says
that there must be traces but Morris
doesn't include such an episode and it
suggests a reluctance or inability to
tackle what's obviously a vital question
it's a strength of is Utopia that
industry has clearly placed as a
condition of the garden society and of
guests whole dream romance with the
society and with Ellen and I I've
already suggested or tried to suggest
that it's just it's a strength that his
placement of handicrafts in relation to
industry allows him to come up with
interesting strategic thinking but that
the condition isn't thought through in
the utopia itself means that industrial
labor knows a moment of revenge against
the work pleasure insinuating a point of
view from which all the gardening is a
leisurely distraction and infecting the
various crafts with a suspicious
secondary nests that the condition isn't
thought through is also a part of the
reason that the news from nowhere though
remarkably realistic is often said it
remains a utopian romance timorous is
credit he probably meant his title to
include this ambiguity
thank you very much chris has told me
that he will answer himself directly
yeah yeah
well I'm not quite sure could you put
the last part of your question again are
you suggesting that they religious yeah
yeah what's a hard question it's a good
question and a hard one to answer I
agree that there's a Masonic aspect to
the Communist Manifesto
I think it's intentionally there that is
that that that that that they're writing
in the wake of religious you know
prophetic texts and sort of recognize
themselves to be doing so in in
respective their beliefs I mean there
are the question as to whether they
think it seems to me that that what you
can say is that they kind of revise they
revise the impression that you take from
the manifesto that capitalism is a
secularizing and-and-and-and system and
that it tends to bring like atheism you
know into to make that sort of socially
available and obvious in a way that it
hasn't been before
I think that's revised when in capital
with a theory of fetishism okay which
however is it I mean Marx is still
seeing this as is systematically induced
kind of quasi religion or a system of
religion I think actually he's in the
first like part of capital or in the in
the part about the fetishes and low
commodities he's pretty you know there's
this idea that this is like the new
religion of of the system okay and it's
it's not that we have a really secular
system it's that you know it's that
there's a new kind of illusory belief
that's that's different that's difficult
or impossible to get away from I guess
but I continue to think that he's that
that both Marx and Engels are sort of
taken for granted agnostics in their own
lives I mean whether they think that
it's never possible for a society to be
without religion I I don't I don't know
how to answer that but I think that they
they they've recognized at least you
know by you know the 1860s or so that
it's very unlikely for there to be a
secular society in the sense of one that
where we looked at religion isn't a
prominent instance okay but I don't
think that they're actually I mean that
their religious themselves I guess I
would I'd also what Jameson often says a
moment in Jameson is you know that the
religious comparison with religion kind
of cuts cuts both ways that Marxist
shouldn't shy away from it that you know
that Marxism is a belief system and that
you know that there are lots of you know
it implies a lot of good things as well
as you know negative things I don't see
it as a debilitating criticism yeah
hmm I may be finally okay I think in the
moment the main the main spirit of the
manifesto is its pragmatic it's
complicated because it's both prophetic
but also there's this notion that the
first thing we need to get done is to to
attack private property and I also think
there's a kind of modesty about it too
you know that it would be presumptuous
of us to say what society is eventually
going to look like that it's for the
people to make that that decision okay I
do think though that they do they're
there in fact a lot harsher or harder on
utopian thinking then they then they
were in other places and so on there is
a there's an episode it would have come
before the manifesto I think it's 1847
Marx wrote a piece in response to cab a
cab a was a utopian socialists who had a
sir he'd written a novel I think called
the voyage to Icarus to Atari he was the
kind of furry Erised thinker okay and he
had just he put out an advertisement in
a paper or asking people to come join
him I can't remember where they're going
I think they wound up in Missouri or
someplace like that they set up a social
utopia and socialist society Marx I
think was friends with with g'day anyway
he writes that you know Citizen Quebec
has done us you know a lot of good by
writing utopian novels you know the
speculation is valuable and you know it
helps to prepare us but he said he's
absolutely wrong in in and what he's
undertaking now he's taking good people
out of the struggle leaders and you know
the people who believe you know as we do
and so he's hurting the struggle here he
also you know he doesn't seem to realize
that that I put one educates oneself and
changes oneself through struggle
that in fact if you get a bunch of
like-minded people and you put them in a
radically new situation what's going to
happen is it you're gonna find out that
all the old problems come come out again
and you're gonna fail and people will be
demoralized and so on but the point is
you know he does say there he's very
clear about the value of the utopian
novels that that kebaya has has written
and so you know there it's clear that it
has a place so I would argue that the
harshness towards utopia in the
manifesto is pretty much it's a matter
of the moment the conjuncture
realization our realization that there's
a kind of weird heavy industries thing
happening on the other side of the
curtain mm-hmm that makes as you as you
put it the provides the condition for
this faux medieval handicraft garden and
I want to press you on your sense of the
of the status of that uneasy recognition
that the text doesn't make you know
heavy weather about but nonetheless it
it brings it brings the problem to to
the to the surface what's happening
there is it Morrises is Morris realizing
or allowing himself to speak a kind of
critique of of a communism or a
socialism that he he feels he's not
comfortable articulating explicitly or
is this a kind of a little eruption of a
self-criticism that sort of surfaces
within the work is that what's the is it
is there a kind of manifesto within the
manifesto or is it a kind of intensive
self reflection of though on some level
the unworkability
of all of this yeah I I do think that it
it's perhaps it's self criticism
that's going on I'm not sure whether I
position on it is entirely clear Morris
I I think Morris actually he probably
actually did believe in some combination
of industry and handicrafts I think that
there's very little doubt that he really
believes strongly in in handicrafts and
and the idea in the idea that any kind
of society worse itself needs to have
work be meaningful and pleasurable
everybody's work that you know I think
you can I mean it means something that
he he doesn't just he doesn't make out
that this kind of society is possible
without factories somewhere huh ok it
means a lot
ok I tend to see it I mean the kind of
episode that I was talking about it in
it is something that could be included
it seems to me maybe he didn't want to
do that because it would have spoiled
the general effect you know if it would
have made for a kind of harder and more
complicated utopian society than he then
he you know then he wanted to surrender
and Morris was he wasn't exactly the
forms of literature that he seems to
have liked tend to get called escapist
ok so he wrote these romances you know
he's interested in these romances in
ways that a lot of people art because he
was like interested in Nordic culture
and tribal cultures and he's interested
in you know what what in the possibility
of connecting somehow through romance
with this kind of with this kind of
mentality or socially thoughts but it's
also he also just you know he didn't
like novels okay he didn't like the kind
of complications that you get a novel
and so I think there's perhaps a
reluctance on that in that regard to get
it you know to get into this whole
business but I kind of wish you know
either tried to include it that probably
came out or I don't know included an
appendix or something something like
that so that you could read it
separately and
and that would help you understand
he's very
I didn't catch the last but I'm sorry
yeah he uses extreme terms - hmm yeah
yeah well on the last I think mean that
that's unfortunate but but you do get
this I think it's all the way through
you get a sharp distinction between the
real working class and like lump ins
okay look when prelate proletariat whom
he sees as like utterly distinct and he
tends to cast them as you know just as a
harmful political force to mean they can
argue will be organized by anybody and
they'll do terrible things any else okay
technically there's a distinction
between those people and then people who
are kind of honestly unemployed okay
because he does there's this whole rap
in later marks on how capitalism
produces unemployment right and that's
and that the industrial reserve army is
absolutely essential to the system so he
has to distinguish between the people
the industrial reserve army which is
like the capable the people who
sometimes work or remain capable and
then the people who are outside it and
it just it looks like you know an
age-old distinction between the worthy
poor and and you know the useless poor
that he shouldn't you know that he
shouldn't have recourse to okay in fact
I mean that's one of the things about
the manifesto I think that doesn't I
mean it's weathered well in the sense
that you read it and you think gee you
think about the Occupy movement and how
I always forget the percentage but 1
percent of the population of the u.s.
controls what percentage of the
resources I don't know is somewhere
between 30 and 60 because I'm a literary
person I can never remember these these
things but it's you know it's an
astonishing amount I think it's closer
to 60 then 30%
the resources
you know the manifesto if you think
about things like that
the manifesto seems prophetic okay but I
do think that that you know that the
idea that the industrial working class
is absolutely central and definitive of
the working class that that's that
that's outdated seems mean that's that
that it's very difficult to imagine an
industrial working class serving in the
way that politically in the way that
Marx did which which means that one
needs to think about the working class
and in a more inclusive way and that the
terms or the ideas are there in Marx I
mean because capitalism is defined as a
system where you know you've got capital
and then you've got free labor of
various sorts okay in between there all
kinds of people he clearly didn't pay
enough attention to or take enough
account of the people in between okay
which is a very numerous faction and so
on but you without people who need to
work to live you're not gonna have
capitalism and that is a historically a
distinctive situation according to to
Marx okay anyway there's no reason to
pick out the industrial work force is
the only you know as the only possibly
radical element of what about there are
all kinds of other workers than people
who work in factories what about them
too so I mean it seems to me that that
part you know needs to be that's a
weakness and it needs to be rethought it
has been to some extent
I believe there's a there will be a
reception just just down the hall here
and if any of you have questions further
questions for our Miss Kendra Kim I'm
sure he would take them over cheese but
Chris thank you so much for coming back
to Yale on this wonderful talk